اسطنبول مع اقتراب الانتخابات
الرئاسية والتشريعية المقررة في
لاجتماع وزراء الخارجية العرب
الموافقة بالاجماع على عودة
الخارجية التركي مولود جاويش
اوغلو ان تركيا رفضت مقترحا
القوات البرية للحرس الثوري. الى
القاهرة حيث اعلن البيان الختامي
دخلت من دون اي اتصال لاسلكي في
منطقة العملية التي حددتها
البولنديين ثلاث مرات من دون
مسافة الامان اللازمة. ما الذي
سوريا لشغل قعدها في الجامعة
العربية. واستئناف مشاركة الوفود
احدا في الادارة الامريكية بنية
روسيا? ما رأيكم انتم? وبالعودة
للاجواء قالت وزارة الدفاع
الرومانية ان طائرة مقاتلة روسية
اعترضت في المجال الجوي الدولي
فوق البحر الاسود طائرة بولندية
كانت تقوم بمهمة مع الوكالة
الاوروبية لحرس الحدود والسواحل
بوتين عام الفين واحد عشر. علم
خلاله كلينتون بان غزو اوكرانيا
زيلنسكي. فلما ينفق الغربيون
عليك مئات مليارات الدولارات
نشرته وكالة رايا نوفوستي
الروسية ويظهر استيلاء جنود
الاشتباكات الدائرة مع القوات
الاوكرانية. اما بالنسبة لفاجنر
وسقطت في منطقة غابات كما اسقطت
اثنتان منها فوق البحر. الاوكران
اعلن حاكم سوفاستوبول. ميخائيل
رزفجايف صد هجوم اوكراني مسيرة
ايفانوفو شمال شرق موسكو. وقال
جهاز امن الدولة في بيان. ان
بوحدات عسكرية شيشانية ها هو
يعود مجددا انه تلقى وعدا
توجد محطة النووية. وعبر جروسي
عن قلقه من تزايد الاعمال
بمسيرة اوكرانية على مطار
سيفيرني العسكري. في مقاطعة
للعلن لا يوجد امام اوكرانيا الا
ان تفاوض روسيا. وسلاح الجو
جنودها في البحر الاسود باربع
حاملات صواريخ من نوع كاليبار.
الروسي يخترق الاجواء البولندية
ثلاث مرات متتالية. مصر تفتح
فشلت في تحقيق النجاح في المعركة
المحتملة. الفشل غير مسموح به يا
للجيران رأي اخر. احداث اليوم.
اجرى الحرس الثوري الايراني
ليونيل ميسي لناديه باريس سان
جيرمان المنافس في الدوري
فهل تكون اثيوبيا المستفيدة
الوحيدة من حرب السودان ام ان
اربعمائة لاوكرانيا. وفي تركيا
ايضا نظم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
بهدف تحرك جديد بسد النهضة
المختلف عليه مع القاهرة
والخرطوم. بالوقت الذي كشفت
معلومات عن زلزال ضرب المنطقة
الاتحاد الاوروبي صدمته باقدام
القوات الاسرائيلية على هدم
الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري.
واكد اردوجان ان عدد الحضور
بنجاح اختبار صاروخ فجر خمسة
المجهز برأس حربي حراري في
امريكيا بتسليم منظومة صواريخ
الدفاع الجوي الروسية اس
السودانية المصرية حركة نشطة
للفارين من السودان الى مصر بسبب
منذ بدء المواجهات بنحو اثني عشر
الف شخص من السودانيين ورعايا
بسبب قيامه برحلة الى السعودية
وغيابه عن حصة تدريبية. ابدى
مدرسة الممولة من جانبه شرق بيت
بالضفة الغربية. اكد وزير
الفوضى والحرب. كشفت تقارير
حديثة معلومات عن محاولة اثيوبيا
اردوغان زعيم تحالف الجمهور
مؤتمرا انتخابيا في مدينة
دول اجنبية. وبينما يعاني
السودانيون الامرين في قلب
يخبئه الدب الروسي للبولنديين?
السودان يشتعل مجددا? مع استمرار
الفرنسي لكرة القدم ولزملائه في
الفريق اليوم الجمعة بعد ايقافه
مقاتلة روسية تواجهت مع مقاتلة
بولندية قبل يومين فوق البحر
استغلال انشغال الدول المجاورة
بما يحدث في السودان من قتال
السورية في اجتماعات مجلس
الجامعة اعتبارا من الاحد. اعتذر
رومانيا ونفذت مناورات عدوانية
وخطيرة من طائرة حرس الحدود
موجات النزوح من السودان? حيث
يشهد معبر اركين على الحدود
ليخبر العالم بانه كان على علم
بنية بوتين لغزو اوكرانيا. بيل
علاقتهما مؤخرا. وذكر حرس الحدود
البولنديون ان الطائرة الروسية
كلينتون الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق.
جرى حديث بينه وبين فلاديمير
المواجهة بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع. ويقدر عدد الذين عبروا
بشأن تقديم ضمانات امنية لنقل
الاسلحة النووية السوفيتية
الاسود واصفا الامر بالاستفزاز
المتعمد حيث ان البلدين توترت
المعارك من جهة وانطلاق
المفاوضات من جهة اخرى. تتواصل
الرد جاء عبر المتحدث باسم
الحكومة البولاندية الذي قال ان
الموجودة في اوكرانيا الى موسكو.
وهل يعقل ان كلينتون لم يخبر
بلاده لمعاهدة بودابست الموقعة
عام الف وتسعمائة واربعة وتسعين.
قادم لا محالة. حيث اعرب حينها
رئيس الحكومة الروسية بوتين برفض
اوكرانيا. وفي ظل الترقب الغربي
للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد. واشنطن
التي قلبت الموازين وبعد تصريحات
رئيس مجموعة فاغنر يفجيني
بوست تكتب في طياتها ان اوكرانيا
قد تلجأ للمفاوضات في حال ما
فاغنر على المركبة الامريكية
التي بدت معطوبة بشكل جزئي جراء
عليها قوات فاغنر في منطقة
باغمود شرق مقطع الفيديو هذا
تشاهدونه هنا هي مركبة مصفحة
امريكية من طراز هام في استولت
لتبحث عن المفاوضات مجددا. وهنا
وبعد اثني عشر عاما يظهر احدهم.
الهجوم ومنسقيها وقيادتها التي
كانت تتعاون مع الهيئات الامنية
الاوكرانية الخاصة. ومن الهجمات
الجوية الى الغنائم العسكرية. ما
منه تدمير طائرات الانذار المبكر
الروسية اي خمسون. واكد جهاز امن
الهجوم كان بتخطيط من
الاستخبارات الاوكرانية. وكان
بالحصول على ذخائر واسلحة جديدة
لاستكمال القتال في شرقي
لم يكتفوا بذلك. فقد اعلن جهاز
امن الدولة الروسي احباط هجوم
بريجوجان. انه يعد للانسحاب من
فاخموت وطلب استبدال قواته
الدولة الكشف عما اسماه المجموعة
التخريبية التي كانت تعد لهذا
العسكرية في منطقة المحطة التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسية.
جروسي البدء باجلاء السكان من
مدينة انير جودار الاوكرانية حيث
جانب اخر اكد المدير العام
لوكالة الطاقة الذرية رافاييل
اسقطت خمسة مسيارات انتحارية
روسية خلال يوم امس السبت من
روسي. بينما قالت القوات الجوية
الاوكرانية ان دفاعاتها الجوية
اعلنت السلطات فيهما مقتل ستة من
موظفي ازالة الالغام في قصف
على المدينة. واضاف الحاكم ان
احدى المسيرات خرجت عن السيطرة
الاوكراني المضاد لاستعادة
الاراضي التي اصبحت في معدة الدب
بعض المقاطعات. هنا مسؤولون
اوكرانيون يصدرون انذارات من
الرد الاوكراني جاء سريعا. وبعد
استهداف الكرملين بطائرات مسيرة
الاوكرانية الجوية اسقطت مسيرة
روسية وان خطر الهجمات متواصل.
الروسية. ترقب يكسوه الصمت وتفوح
منه رائحة الخوف. ونقصد الهجوم
فيما سمع دوي انفجارات عدة وقعت
في دينيميرو وخراسون اللتين
ترفض طلب امريكا. ومليون وسبعمئة
الف تركي يصفقون له. ساعة الصفر
واعلنت حالة تأهب جوي جنوبي
البلاد. فيما قال عمدة الدفاعات
ايران تكشف عن سلاح جديد. وسوريا
تعود رسميا للحضن العربي. وتركيا
موسكو تكشف سر خدعة انسحاب قوات
فاجنار من بغمود. وامريكا تقولها
غارات جوية روسية لمناطق تغطي ما
يقرب من ثلثي البلاد. بدورها
ابوابها للسودان. واثيوبيا تستغل
الفوضى السودانية تتوعد بالتدخل.
وقوات فاغنر تفشي سر امريكا
المدفونة في اوكرانيا. بينما
قالت قيادة عمليات الجنوب
الاوكراني ان روسيا عززت مواقع
الروسي توازيه تحركات عسكرية
موضع لقوات الطرفين واجلاء لسكان
تجاوز المليون وسبعمائة الف شخص.
السيارات الاوكرانية تتساقط
بغزارة على الاراضي الروسية.